good morning how are you hi carlos i'm
very well how are you
i'm doing excellent thank you i got to
ask you you know as myself i was a big
fan of the matrix growing up
who
when they found out that you were going
to be in this new movie was the most
excited in your family in your life
ah
i think there would be tough competition
between
um in my family you said right yes
because in my life my team was most
excited but in my family i think it
would be tough competition between my
mom and my husband
oh yeah among the two of them who do you
think is the bigger matrix fan like who
is
who knows more about the movies
well i don't know about either of them
knowing too much about movies but i
think that everyone is a fan of the
matrix because
of the sheer fact of what the matrix
movies did when they came out and how
much they still mean to people
was there any sort of pressure that you
felt yeah i mean given that the matrix
kind of changed everything when the
first one came out
you know going into this one what sort
of pressure was there to
i don't know if it's replicate that or
add to it
well i think i mean i i'm not taking on
the pressure of the entire movie because
you know obviously this is a non-some
cast and um it is predominantly
the story of neo and trinity and um you
know sort of the continuation of the
first movie but i was intimidated i
won't lie my first scene was
with the entire cast
where i speak
all my lines in the movie um in one
sunset so i had like 45 minutes to just
make sure i got everything right so it
was terrifying and especially with you
know jada carriane and keanu standing in
front of me i was like
you gotta get this right girl and um
and i did i did a lot of prep and but i
won't lie it was intimidating
you know with the way that um
movies are made now and the special
effects of being so great there is sort
of this idea of like
what are we seeing that's real and what
are we seeing that's not how much of
your experience
was practical in this film
there was there was a lot of practical
because i had to use my hands for
um a lot of the work that i'm doing in
the movie but um i'm a big fan of
technology and i love the amalgamation
of film and technology that has happened
in the last two decades i think that um
there's something so great about being
able to
have an
massive imagination and know that you
can be supported in being able to make
that happen um i find that really fun
fun and it's almost like magic
to see
if someone's giving you the choice today
someone walked up to you with really
cool black glasses on and was like red
or blue
what are you taking
at this point i've had a whole year
where i've worked a lot and i'm i'm
ready to go back home so i might take
the blue pill for like a little while
but i'm a red pill kind of girl i think
right you're like can i just take let me
just hit some news on half of it yeah
half of it
that's awesome well frankie thank you so
much for the time congratulations on the
movie um very very excited for everyone
to see it thank you so much happy
holidays all the best